[Musique]
pour vous
qu'est ce qu'une personne humaine
question simple évidente mais complexe à
la fois
de tout temps les philosophes l'on
étudié on ma part je pense qu'il est
important voire urgent de se reposer la
question
alors j'ai eu la chance il y a vingt ans
de rencontrer le père marie dominique
philippe théologien et philosophe ses
enseignements m'ont ouvert les yeux sur
la notion de la personne humaine et de
la recherche de ces finalités
il m'a aidé à structurer ma pensée est à
découvrir de nouvelles disciplines comme
la philosophie
moi qui suis de base de formation
ingénieur et école de commerce il a
repris étudié en qualité de philippe de
disciple d'aristote les quatre notions
principales de tout être humain
alors pour aristote la première finalité
la plus évidente plus immédiates pour
lui c'est le travail alors nous allons
mettre de côté le travail s'avère un peu
robotisée savez celui qu'on voit dans le
film les temps modernes de charlie
chaplin puis là je ne pense pas qu'on
puisse y épanouir n'en prenons le
travail au sens large
prenez un artiste un artiste que va-t-il
faire le travail et des journées et des
nuits entières pour créer son oeuvre
un artisan va façonner la matière de ces
mâts pour la m suivant ses idées ou ses
plans un sportif il va s'entraîner
pendant des heures pour faire son chrono
vous voyez qu'il y a plein de modalités
du mot travail de cette expérience pour
aristote le travail a une place
importante dans nos vies et est un
moteur essentiel de notre épanouissement
la deuxième finalité d'aristote
c'est l'amour à l'amour l'amour
les philosophes l'ont mise plusieurs
graduation en partant de l'eros pour nos
désirs charnels jusqu'à l'agapé d'amour
divin en passant par la camaraderie
lamonde amitié qu elle fila
prenons ces différentes modalités pour
enrichir pour chacun d'entre nous notre
vie sentimentale est effective
d'ailleurs pour aristote matin de cette
finalité n'est pas temps d'aimer mais de
se savoir aimé en retour et c'est dans
cette relation là qu'on peut toucher le
bonheur dépasserions ainsi de beaucoup
nos désirs égoïstes
pour la 3eme finalité on faire un petit
test
alors je vais vous demander aussi de
fermer les yeux ne vous inquiétez pas je
pense qu'on est tout seul
cet après midi donc fermer les yeux et
vous vous imaginez sur une superbe plage
fait beau d'entendre les oiseaux du
petit à petit la mer vous sentez les
grains de sable sur votre peau vous êtes
bien
relaxez vous détendez vous deux petits
facteurs supplémentaires
petit mais de taille le premier vous
n'avez pas de smartphone ni tablettes ni
le téléphone super génial le deuxième
cette île paradisiaque sur laquelle vous
êtes et bien c'est une île déserte
vous voilà devenu robinson crusoé
fantastique non
robinson crusoé sur une île déserte
alors maintenant la question de ce petit
jeu pouvait ouvrir les yeux si vous le
désirez c'est combien de temps
pensez-vous tenir comme robinson crusoé
sur cette île déserte
pour les risques pour les accros des
réseaux sociaux
allez on vous donne entre une heure
voire une journée pour tout achat qu une
semaine peut-être un mois qui veut
tenter l'aventuré d'être robinson crusoé
pendant une année
sur cette île déserte paradisiaque mais
déserte et sans téléphone
j'ai beau regarder je vois pas beaucoup
de bras se lever et c'est là qu'on
rejoint d'un troisième finalité
d'aristote qui la relation la communauté
la vie en société
non nous ne sommes pas faits pour vivre
seul
la quatrième finalité d'aristote c'est
la contemplation et là vous pouvez faire
cet exercice tous les jours vous prenez
quelques minutes où que vous soyez vous
pouvez prier pouvait méditer vous pouvez
contempler la nature vous verrez ces
instants-là deviendront indispensables
dans vos vies alors si nous reprenons
les quatre finalité d'aristote le
travail l'amour la vie en société et la
contemplation pense qu'il est important
pour vous pour chacun d'entre nous de
regarder comment elles peuvent interagir
dans nos vies
comment pouvons nous les mettrons nous
pouvons les mettre en oeuvre
comment nous rendent tél en fin de
compte plus humain cet après midi vous à
l'écouté d'autres spica quand des choses
fantastiques à vous raconter
pour certains ou certaines d'entre eux
d'entre elles se sont arrêtées un
instant dans leur vie et ont essayé d'y
trouver un sens en un mot il essaye de
toucher leur finalité
mais alors dans ce cas là comment
fait-on pour les personnes en situation
de handicap mental
ont-elles une vraie place dans la
société
est-ce que nous ne cachons pas par peur
par confort pour nous
par sécurité un des grands enjeux de
notre société aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
puisse toucher elle aussi leur finalité
alors pour illustrer mes propos je vous
rends compte je vous racontais quelques
rencontres anecdote que j'ai avec m la
première il s'appelle dominique nous
avons quatre mois de différence je ne
dirais pas qu'il est plus âgé un les mon
oncle nous avons grandi ensemble et le
fait d'avoir grandi ensemble a fait
permettre de ne pas voir le handicap et
la personne avant tout nourrir et jeux
d'enfants ont fortement contribué à
modifier mon regard sur le handicap
je me souviens d'ailleurs d'un repas de
famille où dominique me parlé avec
enthousiasme de la fabrication de tapis
au sein de son entreprise
je me suis rendu compte à ce moment là
que le travail était très important pour
lui
tu as eu permettait entre autres de
prendre des vacances ils aiment aller de
temps en temps sur les plages du
débarquement en normandie se souvenir
que son père avait été fait prisonnier
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
ou alors d'aller voir des matchs de
football de son équipe préférée le losc
aline fort de cette relation fallu
plutôt filiation bien sûr et de 14h
depuis quatorze ans que je travaille
dans le secteur du handicap mental je
m'efforce de faire rencontrer des
écoliers collégiens et lycéens avec ces
personnes ont changé leur regard
notamment mathilde jeune collégienne qui
était venu avec ses camarades changer
des activités pendant un après-midi qui
vient me voir avec un grand sourire en
me disant monsieur monsieur monsieur
vous m'aviez dit qu'ils étaient gentils
mais c'est vrai depuis a fait des études
d'éducatrice récemment un éducateur qui
me rapporter les paroles d'une maman a
vraiment de marie qui était tout étonné
toute joyeuse de voir que des jeunes
filles
maintenant on disait bonjour à leur
fille quand elle est là la piscine
grâce à ces rencontres
dans le domaine sportif maintenant mois
d'escaladé
c'est pas mon truc dès que j'arrive à
deux mètres ce à peu près là je flagelle
je me suis tétanisé je ne bouge plus
frédéric lui il grimpe comme spiderman
et il a une hémiplégie du côté droit
donc avec un seul bras frédéric dépasse
handicap
je vous raconte pas la joie qu'il a
lorsqu'il a atteint le sommet
autre exemple xavier vous aviez lui
c'est notre public relations m chaque
visite
bonjour comment allez vous je m'appelle
et xavier et toi accueil chaleureux non
xavier aime aussi l'équitation
il n'a pas fallu beaucoup de temps pour
grimper sur le dos de boboul allez-y je
voudrais vous y voir vous grimpez sur le
dos d'un cheval
même si c'est un poney pour louis j'ai
une petite requête à vous faire parce
que nicolas veux pas me le donner j'ai
besoin du téléphone de nicolas de tony
parker
il sait que je suis ici cet après-midi
oui il m'a dit je veux le numéro de
téléphone de tony parker parce que je
veux jouer dans son équipe
et oui louis passionné de basket il a sa
licence il s'entraîne toutes les
semaines et le dimanche il va boire
souvent les matches de son équipe
préférée au début nicolas leur
entraîneur avait peur il me faisait part
de ses peurs ne peut être pas savoir les
faire jouer au basket ou de leurs
réactions un peu imprévisible depuis
plus de trois centres viennent jouer
régulièrement chez eux ont la plus
grande joie de tous et de véritables
amitiés se sont créées entre eux alors
des sports jeux pesant du site et
d'autres le rugby escrime landman la
piscine voir d'autres qui sont pratiqués
régulièrement avec ces personnes
les choix importants à retenir c'est
qu'il faut que nous ou des passions nos
peurs pour qu'elles puissent les
pratiques et comme tout à chacun
et comme le sport n'a pas d'âge je vous
parlais de geneviève une dame de 65 ans
qui a entre autres une polyarthrite
elle vient de découvrir le handball il
s'y adonne avec joie et passion
il suffit pour nous de changer un peu
les règles dans le domaine artistique
beaucoup elle la peinture
voyez aurore aime faire des copies de me
roy soins avec son adaptation elle lors
d'une exposition vente une dame était
tombé en admiration devant un tableau et
l acheter le tableau au nez à la barbe
de la maman de guillaume parce que ce
tableau était beau et ça prouve bien
qu'ils ont du talent pour raconter
encore d'autres anecdotes tenait fabien
et elodie or fabien ta jeune homme d'une
trentaine d'années bien beau la des
troubles autistiques pas bien elle trois
choses entre autres la première il aime
les jolies éducatrice je puis vous dire
qu'il a très bon goût
la deuxième il aime aller en savoie tous
les ans en vacances
il a des origines familiales la
troisième connaît tous l'étape parker
c'est un tat cynophile averti elodie et
le dit c'est notre petit rayon de soleil
petit bout de femme toujours le sourire
nous aimons jouer des petites saynètes
entre nous à ce moment là je deviens le
prince igor qui emmène la princesse
elodie la mède ans à toul
il en fallait et je mets trois gardiens
devant sylvain philippe eric il ya ce
moment là bien sûr le soldat ryan bien
la sauver alors des anecdotes je peux
vous en raconter d'autres que je
pourrais vous demandez simplement c'est
peut-être de retenir cette phrase que
j'ai lu récemment elle avait été elle a
été écrite par une artiste belge la
personne handicapée
pas besoin de bons sentiments elle a
juste besoin qu'on lui donne une place
pour exister
alors maintenant à vous de jouer oui
rencontrer les accueillaient les passer
du temps avec elle ouvrit en bas ils
vont vous ouvrir leur coeur merci pour
eux
[Applaudissements]